F: Salut, je suis à Lille.
J'ai le droit de dire où t'habites ?
C: Euh, à Lille oui.
** générique **
F: Et je suis donc avec Cyril, alias Super Konar de la chaîne Super Konar, Monsieur Cyril !
C: Enchanté.
F: Qui a eu la gentillesse de m'offrir un "fish and chips" pour m’appâter jusqu'ici.
C: "Fish and chips" du Nord. Totalement atypique.
F: Comme vous avez pu le voir dans le titre, je vais essayer de faire un truc de mentalisme sur Cyril.
C: Il ne m'a pas menacé, il ne m'a pas payé.
F: Il ne m'a pas demandé de dire ça.
F: J'ai une vrai question à poser à Cyril alors n'y répond pas. Mais si tu devais te réincarner et que dieu te disait :
"La réincarnation pour toi ça sera forcément dans un jeu vidéo." Tu pourrais être n'importe quel objet ou personnage, ce que tu veux dans un jeu vidéo.
Je vais te demander de réfléchir à quoi ça pourrait faire référence et je vais essayer de trouver ça. Tu vois un peu l'idée ?
C: Ok
F: Tu vois, si demain tu meurs, ooooooooh
Attends, on fais ohhhhhhhhhh
ooooh, il est mort
C: oh je suis mort
F: Ah c'est pour ça qu'on le vois plus dans les tendances ?
Nan, c'est autre chose ça !
Et toi t'es mort tu fais 'aaaah zut alors'
Ah mais j'ai un choix assez cool
C: OK
Je vais peut être vouloir me réincarner en .....
En un pot de fleur dans Hitman ou directement en un truc particulier
C: Préparation mentale, tu fais face à un mur
F: ok !
C: Bonne chance !
F: Donc tu as ta réincarnation en tête ?
C: Ouais
F: OK
Mais je sais pas si c'est un objet, un personnage,  ou autre chose. Peut être un objet d'un jeu vidéo
Ou un objet qui sert à jouer au jeu vidéo
Ou une arme de jeu vidéo
Putain le mec il commence déjà à donner des contre indices tu sais
Nan mais c'est ça
mais une arme c'est un objet par exemple
C: Ouais
F: Moi je pense que tu es plus parti sur un objet
C: Non
F: Mais je... veux pas ta réponse
C: Ah
*rires*
F: A chaque fois je suis pas très précis ce qui me permet d'avoir des infos
C: Ah d'accord
F: Mais dis toi que, sauf si je te demande de répondre en disant 'vas y répond moi à ça'
Sinon ne répond jamais
Ecoute je pense que t'as pas choisis un objet, ça c'est, tu vois j'ai des certitudes
C: Oh merde ! Il est fort !
F: C'est un peu bluffant, et je te propose qu'on se revoit pour une autre vidéo , la prochaine fois pour aller un peu plus loin
C: Salut !
F: Ça va ? ça t'as plu ou pas ?
C: Ah super !
Le mentalisme hé ;
Comme ça !
F: Abonnez vous
Je me met derrière vous comme ça vous pourrez le regarder aussi dans les yeux
Donc tu regardes ici
L'objectif
Tu penses à la lettre c'est tout, à la première lettre
A B C D E F G H I J K L M N O P Q R S T U V W X Y Z
Je pense que j'ai passé la lettre
Ne répond pas à ça
c'est une certitude
*rire de Fabien*
C: J'essaye de me concentrer tu vois
F: C'est pas si évident que ça
C: Tu vas voir je suis un cas, très difficile
Le mental avant tout
La tombe
F: Je vais le refaire un coup
C: vas y
A B C D E ah tu vois tout à l'heure j'avais une hésitation sur D, je l'ai plus
D E F G H I J K L M N O P Q R S T U V W X Y Z
Nan, si je l'ai
Je l'ai et je vais vous expliquer ce qui se passe
Enfin, si, si, je pense l'avoir en tout cas
R: Ahhh je peux donner de faux indices
F: Attend je vais noter sur ça, ça va être plus visible
En fait  depuis tout à l'heure je te le dis parce que tu pourras regarder la vidéo
D'habitude je cherche ce qui bouge, je cherche les changements de réactions et toi c'est inversé
En fait je trouve que tu as beaucoup de réactions et que juste avant une certaine lettre
ça bouge moins, ça bouge plus et ça reprend après
Je pense que c'est une consonne d'ailleurs
et je vais faire pleins de trait comme ça, pour que tu ne puisse pas anticiper ce que je suis en train d'écrire
est ce que tu peux nous dire vraiment à quelle lettre tu pensais s'il te plait
C: R
F: la lettre R... oui
C: Merde *rire de Cyril* nan !
J'ai failli
F: Tu n'as pas failli. OK
donc... je sais que c'est pas un objet et que ça commence par la lettre R
Alors là ne répond plus
Je pense que c'est un personnage donc c'est quelque chose qui est incarné dans le jeu, c'est ce que je pense ne répond pas à ça
Tu me diras entre un objet et ça y'a pas tant de choix non plus mais quand même  y'a pleins de trucs comme ça
Du coup maintenant il va falloir que je trouve le jeu vidéo en question
Qui commence par R
Est ce que d'après toi je connais ce jeu ?
J'ai pas une grande culture du jeu vidéo, mais quand même
Oui, d'accord.
Donc c'est quelque chose de grand public
OK, ça marche
Est ce que tu pourrais t'imaginer devant toi, comme si y'avait un écran de cinéma
Ton personnage entrain d'agir comme il agit normalement
Si c'est, ça commence par R donc on va prendre Mario, si c'est Mario, imagine le sur un plateforme
Si c'est Tomb Raider, tu l'imagines entrain de grimper quelque part
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Comme si il y avait un séquence a lire
Et là ,il ou elle est entrain de faire quelque chose c'est ça ?
C: Là il faut que j'imagine vraiment la... scène?
F: Oui oui
D'accord, droite gauche c'est un jeu de plateforme ça me va
C'est une affirmation
*rire*
C: Peut être, peut être pas
F: Peut être peut être pas on ne sait pas
Et tu voudrais vraiment être réincarner dans cette personne là, dans ce jeu là ?
C'est un vrai volonté de ta part ?
C: Ouais
F: Ça te ferait plaisir ?
C: Ça me ferait plaisir
F: Ça te ferait marrer ?
C: Ça me ferait plaisir.
F: Ça te ferait plaisir
Maintenant je fais aussi ce qu'on appel du stock reading c'est à dire un petit tunnel avec toutes les informations que j'ai
J'ai un nom de jeu mais là ça n'a pas de sens
Ah j'ai aussi un nom de jeu avec un personnage
Juste comme ça, pour information, ce qui serait sympa quitte a être réincarné dans un jeu de plateforme
C'est de pouvoir voler, de temps en temps
Avec ses cheveux
Des trucs comme ça quoi
C: Ça peut être sympa
F: Moi ça me ferait marrer dans la vie ce serait de pouvoir dissocier mes membres comme ça
D'envoyer mes points là-bas
C: Ouais c'est un peu chelou quand même
F: C'est un peu chelou ouais
C: T'aimerai bien enlever tes membres et tout ?
F: Ouais, bah ça dois bien exister des jeux comme ça non ?
C: Je suis pas sûr...
Je pense que tu devrais changer de voix
F: Ah ouais, moi je te sens bien saouler *rire*
En quoi tu voulais être réincarné ?
C: En Rayman
F: En Rayman, yeeeah
C: Bravo ! Il est bon, il est bon, excellent
Donc ça c'était... le beau jeu
C'est à dire que tu pouvais trouver mais euh
Après si tu aimes le challenge,  on peut aller plus loin
F: Ouais
Je te propose de me challenger dans la prochaine vidéo
C: Bah pourquoi pas ! Pourquoi pas.
F: Tu vois, par skype
C: Par skype
F: Donc encore plus dur pour moi parce que j'ai des retours d'informations différent et euh ça te dit ou pas ?
C: Ouais grave
F: On fait ça, ok
C: Je me préparerai physiquement
* rires *
Le pire c'est qu'à chaque fois que j'ai fais les erreurs   après je me disais 'merde'
Genre quand tu disais l'alphabet je clignais des yeux  et quand j'étais trop concentré sur la lettre qui arrivait
Je faisais plus rien je me disais 'merde il sait que c'est maintenant''
F: Ici, t'avais énormément de, tu sais de petits  mouvements incontrôlés musculaires ici
C: J'avais trop envie de rire en plus j'étais comme ça
F: Et vous connaissez ou pas SuperKonar, je suis pas sûr que toute ma communauté te connaisse
C: Enchanté
F: En fait dites moi un peu, est-ce que y'a des gamer sur la chaîne ?
Parce que moi je joue beaucoup, j'aime jouer
Mais j'ai pas assez de temps pour y consacrer, pour jouer comme j'aimerai
Donc je vais jouer à mes classiques des trucs comme ça, mais je me pose vraiment la question si j'ai des gamer sur la chaîne
Dites le dans les commentaires si vous connaissiez Cyril avant moi, moi je le connais que depuis le moi de Janvier
C: Mouais il était temps ! hein ? T'es en retard
F: J'espère que ça t'a plu
C: Grave, ouais
F: Pour une première approche pour une première fois
C: Ouais
F: Ça valait le coup que je loue un hélicoptère pour venir
C: Exactement, c'est l'hélicoptère que t'as laissé sur le toit d'ailleurs
F: Ouais euh à un moment donné le mec pèse dans le game
Il fait venir des hélico là comme ça
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'éspère que ça vous a plu
Vous pouvez nous mettre des petits pouces en l'air si ça vous a plu
Si vous voulez devenir Rayman
C: Rayman vole et .. et.. Pourquoi j'ai choisis Rayman ? Tu sais pourquoi ?
F: Ah non tiens c'est une vrai bonne question ça, pourquoi t'as choisis Rayman ?
C: Parce que dans les jeux, en fait tu sais pourquoi j'ai galéré?
F: Non
C: Parce que tous les personnages ont une vie de merde
F: Ah oui c'est vrai
C: Genre sa femme, elle est morte. C'est la guerre, il y a des zombies de partout
ils crèvent tous
donc du coup il y en avait pleins où ah ben non lui c'est vrai il a perdu sa femme il est triste et tout
*Rire de Fabien*
C: Lui il est dépressif. Oh lui il fait la gueule et tout
et seul Rayman je me suis dit
Rayman il a toujours le smile
F: Oui
C: Il est toujours content, il vole avec ces trucs, il fout quelque petite patate par ci par là
F: Il s'excuse même après
C: Oui
F: "Oh pardon"
F: Même Mario c'est un plombier à la base
C: Attends le mec ça fait 30 ans qu'il court après une princesse, il l'a pas encore pécho
ah un moment... faut pas déconné
F: Dès qu'il l'a libère, elle repart
C: Elle se fait prendre par Bowser on sait pas ce qui se passe, non plus, dans le château quand...
F: Il y a  même des bébés tortues que tu croises
C: Ouais
F: Découvrez la chaîne de Cyril, si c'est pas déjà fait
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la mienne, bien sûr si c'est pas déjà fait non plus
donc rendez vous demain... à 11h
Tchao !
C: Tchao !
F: Tchao !